hello my friends I am Greg and we're
gonna watch from the chance at a top
trends top trend nine youtubers who did
porn these guys know what porn is what
is porn
exactly it's where like sexual
activities take place where you can
actually watch people having sex and all
kinds of variations they can just be
solo masturbating to a whole orgy full
of many people and you could watch it
for free there used to be a time where
you'd have to pay for this in order to
watch it now if anyone who has
high-speed Internet can easily watch
porn on their mobile device Android
iPhone like any time technology is
amazing watch people having sex yeah
this is amazing it's amazing
and we're youtubers so we've thought
about doing porn not together but
helping each other out she holds the
camera while I'm doing it I love the
camera by her suckas nobody will have
sex with me yeah nobody watches me by
myself I don't know alright let's watch
this video what's up everyone today
we're going to be looking at knowing
youtubers you did porn also if we get
5555 likes for all these youtubers who
have done porn I will make my own porn I
wanna load it to YouTube also leave a
comment oh your favorite porn stories if
you have one also if you haven't entered
the seventeen hundred fifty dollar
giveaway yeah and then could be down
below you can win a some suck series
seven tablet one of two G chair major
racing chairs a beats by dre executive
headset and more anyone can enter we
have to do is click the giveaway link in
the description but oh my gosh yes to
the porno I also got some of the info
from promotion on TV subscribe to helium
by the way number one psycho moms so
coming first on the list of knowing
youtubers who did porn is psycho mom or
Christian Coco
sure not really sure how you say that
name correct me in the comments if I'm
wrong so I'm pretty sure I said that
really badly but Christy and goal call
psycho mom has over 90 thousand
subscribers and has been featured and
seen in a couple of them of Geoghan of
its videos but then a few months ago
someone I'm not sure who managed to find
a psycho mom in an amateur porn video
actually two different videos of her
because I was looking at this a couple
months ago when scash reported on it and
in the comments of his video were the
original video and then people were
linking another one she'd done which was
more intense more sexual surveys I'm not
linking you guys to a porno but because
loads of people hosting and I'm sure
there's still links in that comment
section but the actual proof that came
up was the tattoo without psycho mom has
on her arm on a rocker arm you can see
there's like a selfie that goes around
it and you can pretty much just see this
exact same thing she was in a porno so
the Frankie Project big shout out to
this guy he did some detective work and
found that that she actually was in some
type of amateur porn and I just watched
you guys and honestly it was good
[Laughter]
YouTube channel she has a subscriber
surprise stories on that channel about
sensitive and embarrassing stuff which
pulls in pretty good views obviously it
has to put in pretty good deal
I am surprised number three vitaliy easy
DTV so I'm sure all of you or most of
you probably have heard of or know about
this story already as involves Vitaly
who has nine million-plus subs on
YouTube and is one of the largest Meucci
pranksters he's sort of known for doing
good pranks while used to be known for
doing good pranks now we saw just a gets
arrested to get viral news because the
pranking community I saw just gone to
[ __ ] now everyone's been exposed for
faking pranks but I'm moving on years
ago he starred in a bang Bros porno no
[Music]
clicked on a video and saw the tally
there and that was how its died that's
my guess anyway I don't really see how I
was it could have happened well since
all this came out Battaglia's actually
made his own video explaining his whole
porn story now it's a video and it could
be truth that could be lies it could be
a mix it could be exaggerated you never
know so I don't know what to believe I
mean it seems pretty legit and I don't
think he'd lie about everything I do
believe quite a lot of it but I do think
some of it was a little bit exaggerated
by the end of the day you never know if
YouTube nowadays if you want to leave
your opinion on that video if you
haven't seen it yeah or if you have seen
it leave a comment down below that day I
did take Viagra that [ __ ] didn't work
[Music]
I'm glad I performed well because if I
did I would have been in the porn star
tool today and that's not what I wanted
to do lost her fame was just a random
person so what she decided to do while
start making random
[ __ ] type YouTube videos which
literally made no sense after uploading
it here these videos leafy who I'm sure
all of you know picked up on these
videos made a video on their calling
around saying one on about she claims
she had psychopathic abilities or so
think about is pretty much impossible
and after tea at IKEA went on drama and
debated over this and it was pretty much
the whole joke to be honest well
obviously Tia got some exposure from
this which is what she wanted from the
beginning and since then she currently
of those random videos of her talking
about stuff and has over one hundred
thirty thousand subscribers so I guess
that is the power of leafy and
dramaalert
but mainly leafy everyone yeah but I
don't know I just have this very strange
and of course I have a public which is
like whatever I'm all out there but then
there's another side to me that's like
Oh God number five Mia Rose so Mia Rose
is a porn star of an ex-porn star once
again who turned a gamer and twitch
streamer if you want to Greek exactly
what it says it pretty much says that
exact things possible to do porn and
travel small youtuber with thirteen
thousand subs but she has a lot more
followers on twitch currently 80
thousand which is pretty good but guys
once you search me a row someone else
comes up who has like three hundred
thousand subscribers and I'm pretty sure
she's not a porn star I think she just
has the same name Mia Rose so if you
want to find the right one just type in
Mia Rose porn or something and she'll
come out it's not hard to tell she has
thirteen thousand subscribers the other
one has like three hundred thousand and
obviously if you want to find any of the
actual porn videos for any of these
people you could just search it on
google or if you want I'm gonna link you
you can do that yourself if you want
it's just not about Lena Lena Kim here
okay so like I have a room all day
I love her she's so sleepy body she's
hair fall right back to sleep she's so
exhausted very sorrowful happens so fun
toys collector Disney toy collector is
one of the biggest if not the biggest
toy unboxing channel she currently has
over 7 million subscribers Wow thank you
now help you figure out she was a
plimsoll was pretty much her voiced
there's a clip of her as a porn star
talking which I will show you now now if
you compare that she's very talented in
my day you can tell it's the same person
and then this was also confirmed by one
of the woman's neighbors where she
actually lives now as I said a second
ago she disables all comments on her
videos and I think this is because
people would constantly expose her past
as being a porn star and obviously all
of our viewers are young kids and they
don't want to be seeing that in the
comments section so it makes sense
also you know now think about it fun
toys collector you see our hands all the
time right and all of our videos you see
our hands I searched for her actual porn
star name or whatever and it came upon
one Hubble X videos or something the
first link I clicked the first video I
saw was her listing another girl I'd
literally all these kids are watching
mr. Disney toys I just thought that was
kind of funny and disgusting
we're going to show you an image every
is pretty disgusting number 7 Zeus coli
so Zeus coli is that you try with Evan
375,000 and her porn star name was or
his other nobs miss a was Susannah
Spears now her real name isn't
collide that's actually the fitness
channel she runs where she pretty much
just uploads workout and fitness videos
including lots and lots of fat-burning
exercises and just weight loss videos in
general super legs men who shared her
story way back well horrible the adult
industry can be she hasn't uploaded in
over a year however I'm still gonna
count as a youtuber as she has videos on
YouTube one of her most pronounced is
called in bed with bree olson I'm gonna
show you guys a clip interested in this
young ex-porn star left the adult
industry and shared her story you can
watch in the description it's pretty
similar to bree olson it was last but i
think this story is worse I didn't
actually watch all because the video is
really long but the overall impression I
get from the adult porn industry is that
it's pretty corrupted although a lot of
industries yeah so interesting having
YouTube channel or she has one but she
deleted two awesome videos on fit
premier show on TV managed to get this
image and I would get my own but I can't
find the channel so I'm not sure where
it's garnered and if it's disappeared if
it's been deleted if it's just buried
because it's got new videos and I can't
find it I'm not sure there anyway guys
those were nine youtubers who did porn
thanks for watching
to enter the giveaway those ending in
like a week or so link will be in the
description to go how they mentioned in
the beginning of the video also don't
fit and even like if you haven't already
I'll do that right now all right guys
you can subscribe to top trends
subscribe to top trend link is in the
description box to go to their channel
you see like what I've been doing
normally with these lists as I stopped
them yeah and then I continue uh-huh I
stop talk about it because it's fresh in
my mind so I can comment on it easier
people seem to really not like that yeah
so we're back to this way okay you know
it's about the way they can just watch
the reaction and if they don't want the
commentary the commentary yeah because
who cares about actual commentary
conversation why you psycho mom when I'm
not too interested in I mean it is it is
interesting because they are like
exposed but I'm feeling like bows though
like what makes it exposed
maybe the person did it they know they
did it you know maybe they don't talk
about it oh like an exposure thing it's
exposed because hey I mean it's out
there she like they they don't go out
promoting this just items because they
don't promote it doesn't mean you're
they're exposing something if she was
like an innocent like preschool teacher
he's something yeah then I can see it
being like exposed preschool teacher
does porn but she's psycho mom dude like
a big deal for somebody called psycho
moms and have been a porn star you know
name it's a fair assessment any other I
guess you know yeah I mean I wasn't sure
sir
Shannon Rose Shannon Rose yeah she has
porn written all over I don't think I've
ever seen one of her pornos okay but the
second you see her you're like that is
horse all right beautiful man of course
I mean there's a certain look what no I
don't when I watched porn I don't ever
look at that I'm saying that's - that's
so artificial okay what's your way to
blown up I'm advocating modification so
I can't really that's fair yeah
agree with you on that I feel like if
people want to modify their bodies to
make themselves feel good and it's for
themselves then go for it oh I don't
want a [ __ ] mannequin that talks you
[ __ ] your hand to a video you might
as well you know it might be she's a
porn out there I mean the Shannon Rose
chick I mean good for her seems like
she's a very successful channel
definitely and she seems you know in a
way that I'm surprised a lot of porn
people haven't tried doing which is just
talk about your hide it and get exposed
yeah exactly so I mean I am see I don't
know if I saw anybody actually hiding
and getting expelled like I just don't
buy the expose thing well they don't
really acknowledge it and Thomas might
tell you I maybe the vitality was people
were calling him out yeah so that seemed
like oh [ __ ] something's coming to bite
me in the ass you know that seemed a
little experiment expose eight out of
these nice people were women and he was
the only guy he was the only guy and
there was a mention for a purpose I feel
like could be a little nerve-wracking if
you're a dude yeah do you penis exposed
thank you get exposed one day no no no
well I'm I've waited off of every site
you could think of yeah pornhub redtube
even the old ones 89 calm you still try
to find my porno you'll never find you
ever made a sex tape yeah you know yeah
once you make it you're done dump it
somewhere somebody exposed Greg go look
for it because you know he works with
children with this Vitaly yeah I don't
know it says deep
expose for their penis show I mean I've
been like pretty naked on this channel
before you've been pretty naked with a
sock around my hips my penis you don't
see my penis or balls and it wasn't me
searching it was Greg like watch funny
video need his wife okay got cornered by
John and Greg and they're like I have
you know clockwork oranges things yeah
this is your initiation this vitaliy guy
seems to have handled it pretty well
yeah he seemed like you didn't really
care I guess it applies for a woman yeah
I think something about just your
genitals being fully exposed this is
just kind of scary territory ya know you
know it's amazing how many men and women
like you can just send each other
pictures lover know who's gonna store
and just release a one day event that's
why you never take face shots at
everything else
not the face millenials who better take
some advice from us we're letting you
know that's why I won't do a sex tape
with a significant other unless we're
getting divorced and I want a memory you
should have it was a dish it wasn't
really like there's no sex but there was
some nakedness I don't know but the fans
are gonna love hearing this it's not
anywhere was like a private video
between me and my boyfriend at the time
just saw your phone or a camera it was
on my camera like my ex stole yeah but
it was like okay so you know that thing
with that redhead girl from the office
the really cute awkward one that makes
that [ __ ] video where she's like I'm
gonna this is gonna be so dry I'm gonna
use so much teeth and she like hurt her
you know you never saw that I've seen
every episode of the office no no it
wasn't happy office I'm saying it was
from that girl I don't know her name he
said the office from the office the
actress from the office
the Kimmy Schmidt chick yes her
forgot her name yeah you made that like
parody on YouTube somewhere a long time
ago and it was like I was parroting that
but there was nudity so it wasn't really
a sex tape it's really just stupid well
you used to do like half naked modeling
me yeah I don't know about half naked I
mean I were bikini who's done half naked
very lenient half me then everybody on
the beach is half naked like yeah so
then why is that a big deal because it's
different when you're not on the beach
erotic Tila Tequila liberal when I first
got my space everyone was raving about
who was teasing yes I saw her porno
years ago I didn't even know she did
yeah yeah she saw I think I think like
when I searched her only like one porno
came up really yeah I think there's one
video I don't know yeah I thought she
was popular for being like sexy on
MySpace yeah she was she was like the
before Instagram models there were
MySpace mom yeah she was one of those
she was one of the big ones yeah well
yeah she did have a porno I'm assuming
that ovie if I remember oh really
mm-hm so millions of guys could imagine
there the guy having sex with Tila
Tequila and then when you ejaculate
you're filled with shame and regret and
you know I never feel bad women don't
really have any more men have that like
yeah it was good yeah more men feel I
guess I know moral guilt or shame I
guess I did I mean I don't think women
masturbate as much as men do yeah sure
you guys probably do it so often that
you just feel guilty for just being a
thing all the time and women are just
like you know what's month miss me a
rose no I don't know who Mia roses she
didn't when I saw her face in the way
she's come across some I did she
instruct me as former porn star yeah she
seemed like a regular adorable gamer
girl yeah smooth transition if there's
anything this video is proven to me is
that any porn actress or actor to just
transition into YouTube that's true I
wonder if you could do it the opposite
way around
I think so having a YouTube following
would allow me to do really well in porn
you know good because then I could just
tell my subscribers go over to porno
Vivid Entertainment watch my videos boom
now I'm a huge porn star and known for
reaction react your they can react to my
own porn I could have done differently
yeah I feel like I can bring a real
element take a lot of my real acting
skills I think so and really make poor
something mainstream yeah good I mean it
could be a thing I I were to do people I
would direct my own I would make sure
they have a great story
they're probably primarily B's story I'd
only want the sex of either if it was
necessary you know you know like action
scenes in movies you're like this is
just unnecessary action I'd only want my
sex scenes to be there if that was like
this serves the plot right yeah that's
the kind of people millions of people
with Tina know who's the son Bono
so the Disney one toys collector shoes
be like Disney toys collectors she's
[ __ ] hot he's super super cute but
her channel that has like seven million
people she never face reveals that all
her hands opening the products and
talking about it so I can understand
this would be like an exposed because
she her channel is she doesn't show her
face yeah yeah but it's like directed
towards children so that would be
something that I would see like having
well that's why she was having some bad
sex videos while she was a boy yeah but
she wanted to be a mom she wanted to be
a mom you know honestly if you're us and
what what that means is you just want to
have kids you want to be a parent one
day yeah especially the ones who have
sex without condoms you just you want to
be a mom like even the ones who are like
coming me but on birth control what
you're really hoping for is to get
pregnant subconsciously I firmly believe
I think I really think it's a human it's
a basic primal nature in eating well
yeah it's like oh we're trying to
prevent it but in the moment it's kind
of hot yeah I think I know
better than okay it might be right there
but the sandy summer chicken is really
hot yeah yeah she is she should she just
do both kid toy voice to know it's very
conflicting I've never been interesting
videos though I've never been fisted
good let's go light the fitness chick
hot no yeah I don't know something like
I've seen women would like really toned
stomach and legs what does the impress
me yeah legs men yeah I know I know most
people probably do too I'm really
impressed
really good trying to do like toned are
benchpress you like just no I'd like
that she's incredibly fit yeah so if I'm
gonna be a porn star I got to get a
really good shape there's ron jeremy
didn't you seen a Ron Burgundy ron
jeremy is the anchorman from the but
yeah i mean he wasn't completely in
shape so there's a lot of shape I feel
like man can get away with it ways
definitely I there's a lot of form where
women have to be [ __ ] ah men are
still flabby yes sure yeah alright then
I got a career let's say this for
YouTube algorithm [ __ ] everyone over I
hate you this is my next internet
transition maybe they'll let me do porn
reactions on pornhub well guys is there
anyone they left off this list is there
any youtubers you'd like to see do porn
Gregg Make a Porno
only if there's a way we can make money
off the views I mean there probably is I
think you porno lets you upload yeah do
they do ads maybe we can just like you
know Photoshop our faces on a pupil am I
not a black guy shout-out to Ava Adam
shot Ava Adam yeah well guys if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe you
the real rejects where it's only movie
content that's why real is in the title
just like this video here
I need SR is on the Anita stargazer
Channel and I'm not a porn star believe
it or not one star despite her name she
does not sound like it however I don't
have the body or the face for it so it's
fishing for a compliment not because I'm
there can't say it yeah they all comment
oh come on you know if you pour oh yeah
won't you say it whether I said that or
not need compliments I know I'm very
comfortable with myself and I do not
stand a chance in porn if the girls look
like that that's for sure but you do
Gregg you look barren and Shari rose and
Rose no